В ефірі «heute journal» з
Марієттою Сломкою та Гайнцом Вольфом.
Добрий вечір.
Промова Олафа Шольца про «історичні зміни»
стала несподіванкою для багатьох.
Це пов'язано, зокрема, із заявою про
100 млрд Спеціального фонду
для інвестицій в обороноздатність Німеччини.
Ця заява вкрай здивувала декого у Бундесвері.
Роками Бундесвер скаржився
на дефіцит військової техніки.
Аж раптом така пожертва.
З часу заяви пройшло близько 3 місяців
і поняття «історичні зміни» дещо втратило вагу.
Також щодо 100 млрд євро існують розбіжності
між «світлофорною» коаліцією та Союзом CDU/CSU.
Союз CDU/CSU має погодитися,
щоб через фінансування Спеціального фонду
внесли зміни до Конституції.
Сьогодні врешті сторони повинні дійти згоди.
З Берліну: Карл Гінтерляйтнер.
«Спеціальний фонд», ймовірно, найважливіший проєкт Шольца
з проголошених ним «історичних змін».
Сьогодні вранці у своєму виборчому окрузі
в Потсдамі Шольц небагатослівний щодо Фонду.
Олаф Шольц сподівається,
що вдасться знайти консенсус.
Я сподіваюся на згоду Союзу CDU/CSU
і ми зможемо таким чином реалізувати фінансування.
Безперечною є сума - 100 млрд євро,
але як і куди потраплять ці гроші?
Союз CDU/CSU хоче фінансувати виключно Бундесвер,
а партія Зелених переконана,
що частину коштів варто виділити
на підсилення захисту від кібератак.
Безпека - це більше, ніж лише Інвестиції в Бундесвер.
Наприклад, наразі ми надзвичайно вразливі до кібератак.
Кібербезпека відіграє сьогодні важливу роль.
Тому ми й уряд Німеччини переконані,
що ця сфера захисту
також потребує фінансування.
Ще поки незрозуміло,
як втілюватиметься один із пунктів НАТО -
інвестування 2% ВВП на оборону.
Для запланованого внесення
змін до конституції Німеччини
потрібна більшість, тобто дві третини голосів.
А отже, й підтримка Союзу CDU/CSU.
Але він має чіткі умови.
Ми дали чітко зрозуміти,
що потрібно виконувати 2 обіцянки канцлера
з промови про «історичні зміни»:
100 млрд для Бундесверу і
інвестування 2% ВВП на оборону як один з пунктів НАТО.
Співголова партії SPD Саскія Ескен у програмі «Berlin direkt»
з Шакунталою Банерджі говорить, що не вбачає великих розбіжностей.
Наскільки мені відомо, Бундесвер
займається і кіберзлочинністю,
тому гроші для Бундесверу
могли б бути використані і на кібербезпеку -
сферу, яку терміново потрібно покращити,
чим я також і займаюся.
Але Спеціальний фонд - це гроші для Бундесверу.
Партія FDP готова вести переговори
щодо шляхів використання 100 млрд
і налаштована дуже оптимістично.
Безсумнівно, Бундесвер повинен
отримати більшість коштів.
Питання полягає у тому,
чи є також інші сфери,
що є важливим для безпеки
які сприяють обороноздатності
та які є важливими для безпеки нашої країни.
Про це треба домовлятися.
Наші точки зору не є надто полярними,
тому буде дивно,
якщо ми сьогодні не дійдемо консенсусу.
Тим часом до Міністерства фінансів
прибувають представники партій.
Ймовірно, очікуються тривалі дискусії.
Ми  домовлялися про зустріч з Крістіаном Лінднером,
але він перебуває на переговорах
і, на жаль, не зміг приєднатися.
Шакунтало, те, що переговори затягуються
свідчить про відсутність згоди.
Так, слід багато чого прояснити, адже
100 млрд Спеціального фонду для Бундесверу -
принципова обіцянка Шольца
з його промови про «історичні зміни».
Союз CDU/CSU та «світлофорна» коаліція повинні
дійти згоди щодо Фонду,
оскільки потрібні тобто дві третини голосів
для внесення змін до Конституції.
«Світлофорна» коаліція сперечалася
не лише з Союзом CDU/CSU.
Розбіжності були і в самій коаліції.
Як ми вже чули, Зелені не обмежуються
вузьким визначенням поняття «безпека» та
наполягають також на інвестиціях у кібербезпеку
і у обороноздатність союзників.
Ми бачимо, що сторони почали домовлятися.
Можливо, йдеться лише про нюанси формулювання і
сторони погодяться, Союз CDU/CSU піде на поступки.
Також обговорюється питання,
чи фінансування Фонду
буде здійснюватися з 2% ВВП на оборону
як виконання пункту НАТО чи
йдеться про додаткові кошти.
Отож, багато питань, які ще потрібно уточнити.
Чекаємо на офіційну заяву
З хвилину на хвилину чекаємо на офіційне повідомлення.
Є враження, що сторони зовсім скоро дійдуть згоди.
Дякую, Шакунтало Банерджі.
Тим часом в Україні триває війна.
Російська армія змінила свою тактику:
обмежила свої цілі,
сфокусувалася на конкретних місцях і фронтах,
зосередивши свої сили на Донбасі,
де українці перебувають під постійним вогнем
важкої артилерії та повітряних атак.
За даними української сторони, росіяни використовують
термобаричну зброю, так звані вакуумні бомби
з жахливою величезною руйнівною силою.
Тому Україна просить якомога швидше допомогти
тяжким озброєнням та зенітними ракетними комплексами.
Далі - Домінік Лессмайстер.
Володимир Зеленський відвідав Харків.
Вперше з початку війни український президент
відвідав території за межами Київської області.
Зеленський оглядає масштаби руйнувань,
яких зазнав Харків внаслідок атак російських військ.
Українська армія відтиснула російські війська
з Харківської області.
Кадри з офіційного Telegram-каналу Президента показують,
як Зеленський нагороджує солдат.
Я хочу подякувати кожному з вас
за Вашу службу.
Ви ризикуєте своїм
життям для всіх нас і для нашої держави.
Дякую, що Ви захищаєте
незалежність нашої держави.
Жорстокі бої у місті на Донбасі - Сєвєродонецьку, яке
майже повністю оточене
російськими військами.
За даними українського Генштабу,
бої все ще тривають,
російським військам не вдалося
взяти місто під контроль.
Людям залишається тільки
евакуація з зони бойових дій.
Протягом 2.5 місяців Яна та її діти
практично не виходили з підвалу.
Ситуація стає все небезпечнішою.
Я довго не могла наважитися на евакуацію.
Ніхто з нас не хотів лишати рідне місто,
але через маленьких дітей ми вирішили виїхати.
Станом на сьогодні війна
в Україні триває майже 100 днів.
Тому так терміново Київ наполягає
на швидкій поставці важкої зброї.
Очікувати переговорів між Україною та Росією
найближчим часом не доводиться.
До речі, телефонна дипломатія Олафа Шольца
і Еманнуеля Макрона
не усюди в Європі сприймається позитивно.
Прем'єрміністр Естонії, Кая Каллас,
вважає розмови з Путіним наразі контрпродуктивними.
Якщо ми хочемо, щоб він відчув,
як ізолює свою країну,
не варто телефонувати йому увесь час.
Ізоляція Росії і фінансовий тиск на неї -
передусім цього можна досягти через пакети санкцій ЄС.
Сьогодні у Брюсселі
знову докладають великих зусиль:
усі 27 країн, включаючи Угорщину,
намагаються погодити нафтове ембарго.
З деталями - Анна Геллінек.
«Нафтове ембарго негайно!»,- закликають демонстранти
напередодні засідання саміту
перед будівлею у Європейському кварталі Брюсселю,
де відзавтра глави держав і урядів країн ЄС
зустрінуться,  щоб ухвалити шостий пакет санкцій проти РФ.
Але і сьогодні йдуть попередні переговори,
які загалом тривають 4 тижні і основне питання:
нафтове ембарго проти Росії,
яке викликає багато суперечок серед країн ЄС.
Володимир Зеленський приєднається завтра
до саміту ЄС по відеоконференції
і вимагатиме від Європи
жорсткості і передусім єдності у питанні нафтового ембарго.
Проте досягнути єдності дедалі складніше.
Ми самі були здивовані, як швидко
ми, європейці, реагували до цього часу.
Але зараз почали перейматися
через нафтове ембарго.
Чи вдасться нам таки домовитися
про шостий пакет санкцій проти Росії,
який включає нафтове ембарго?
Ми знаємо, що деякі країни не повністю згодні,
але сподіваюся, нам вдасться дійти консенсусу.
Угорщина опирається поки найбільш рішуче,
відкидаючи також і дворічний перехідний період.
Причина - трубопровід «Дружба».
Його північний рукав постачає російську нафту Німеччині,
а південний рукав відповідає за енергопостачання
Угорщини, Словаччині та Чехії.
Усі три країни не мають виходу до моря
і вимагають для себе виняткового підходу.
Тому зараз ми обговорюємо умови
щодо нафтового ембарго,
які стосуються лише нафти,
що надходить до Європи танкерами.
Але 27 країн ЄС не змогли  узгодити і це.
Фактично Росія доставляє близько 70% сирої нафти
танкерами по Балтійському морю до Західної Європи,
переважно до Роттердама,
а Чорним морем до Південної Європи,
до порту Трієста.
Негайна критика щодо «послабленого» ембарго:
Йдеться про впровадження нафтового ембарго проти Росії,
яке має сенс лише
із залученням усіх держав.
Йдеться також і про спільний пошук
альтернатив російській нафті.
Ось про що зараз має бути мова,
а не про видалення окремих розділів або винятки.
Розбіжності існують і щодо вступу України до ЄС.
У Східній Європі виступають
за негайний статус кандидата для України,
а західноєвропейські країни,
включаючи Німеччину,
радше сповільнюють процес.
Також розбіжності щодо
стратегії розмов і поводження з Путіним.
Шольц і Макрон виступають
за продовження діалогу з Росією,
країни Балтії та Польщі воліють
говорити лише з Україною.
Завтра розпочинається саміт ЄС,
питання про нафтове ембарго все ще відкрите,
але обійти його не вдасться.
І всі знають:
чим довше триває війна,
тим більше розхитується єдність Європи.
А зараз інші новини.
У Північному Рейні-Вестфалії CDU і Зелені
розробили погодження після перших переговорів і
таким чином з'являється «зелене світло»
для безпосередніх переговорів про коаліцію.
Розширений склад правління CDU і Зелені
погодилися на створення коаліції.
Прем’єрміністр Вюст заявив, що
коаліційні переговори розпочнуться у вівторок.
Міністр праці та соціальних питань Гайль
відхиляє підвищення пенсійного віку.
Як повідомив Гайль медіагрупі Funke,
дебати про те, щоб хотіти чи мусити
працювати до 70 років,
він вважає беззмістовними,
тому що це не співвідносне з реальним життям
багатьох громадян Німеччини.
Таким чином Гайль відхиляє думку економістів,
які виступали за підвищення пенсійного віку
через високу інфляцію.
Зі зверненнями за глибинні церковні реформи
і більше зусиль для захисту клімату
завершився 102-й З'їзд католиків Німеччини
у Штутґарті.
На завершальному богослужінні молилися,
зокрема, за людей в Україні,
які страждають від російської загарбницької війни.
У п'ятиденному З'їзді католиків взяли участь
близько 27 000 віруючих,
що значно менше,
ніж на останньому такому З'їзді у 2018 році.
Детальніше про З'їзд католиків у Штутґарті
можна дізнатися з репортажу ZDF
під назвою «Між війною і миром» о 00:35,
а також у медіатеці.
Після масового вбивства в початковій школі
в американському Техасі
президент Байден відвідав місто Ювалд.
Перед школою Байден і його
дружина Джилл поклали квіти.
Згодом вони зустрілися з родичами загиблих і постраждалих.
У громаді відчуття горя переходить у гнів,
тому що мешканці звинувачують поліцію,
що вона запізно увірвалася до школи.
18-річний підліток застрелив
19 дітей та 2 вчителі.
А зараз знову новини Німеччини.
Проїзд «зайцем» є злочином.
Це може статися один раз випадково,
але хто постійно їздить без квитка,
мусить бути покараним.
Це звучить логічно.
Але реальність зовсім інша.
Деталі - у репортажі Крістіана фон Рехенберга.
Кримінальні провадження призводять до того,
що у в'язницях Німеччини на диво багато людей,
тому що вони не змогли
сплатити штраф за безквитковий проїзд.
У колі юристів точаться суперечки,
наскільки такі покарання доречні.
І не тільки міністр юстиції Марко Бушман вважає,
що потрібно зменшувати кількість тих,
хто потрапляє до в'язниці через несплату проїзду.
Пан О. соромиться.
Озираючись у минуле, він жалкує про свій вчинок.
Але і те, як вчинили з ним, він не вважає правильним.
Він не хоче називати своє ім'я.
Пана О. спіймали без квитка, коли він їхав потягом.
Не один раз, а безліч разів.
У Німеччині - це злочин.
Згідно з параграфом § 265a Кримінального кодексу
пан О. був ув'язнений.
Загальний термін - 3.5 роки,
поділені на чотири окремі терміни позбавлення волі.
Але жоден суддя не засуджував пана О.
до позбавлення волі.
Всі чотири процеси завершилися штрафом,
який власне і став проблемою.
Якби я мав стільки грошей, щоб сплатити штраф,
я мав би гроші і на сплату проїзду
та не їздив би «зайцем».
Пан О. тяжко хворий.
Коли він дізнався про хворобу,
його життя розділилося на «до і після»:
втрата житла, депресія, бідність.
Він не може сплатити штрафи, не може їх відпрацювати
- що ж робити?
У Кримінальному кодексі зазначено:
хто не сплатить штраф, тому загрожує позбавлення волі.
Це має відлякувати.
Принцип очевидний.
Проблеми виникають,
коли люди попри усе бажання
не можуть сплатити штраф.
Наприклад, люди у тяжкому становищі,
безхатченки, наркомани,
люди з психічними захворюваннями.
Виходить, ми караємо не за тяжкість злочину,
а за бідність і нещастя.
Але скільки людей саме в такій ситуації?
Ніколь Бегелейн - одна з них з небагатьох,
хто займається дослідженням цієї проблематики.
З тих, хто засуджений до позбавлення волі
через несплату проїзду,
більша частина знаходиться в скрутному становищі.
За даними Бегелейн, близько 650 000 осіб\
знаходяться у в'язниці
через неможливість сплатити штраф.
І це найбільша група таких осіб.
На їх утримання у в'язниці держава витрачає
150 євро на день.
Ці гроші можна було б вкласти у соціальну роботу,
як радять працівники консультаційного центру
для правопорушників.
Ув'язнення лише погіршує ситуацію.
Дуже часто трапляється,
що після ув'язнення все починається знову.
Люди втратили житло,
немає допомоги від держави, немає роботи -
після ув'язнення виникає багато різних проблем.
Пан О. вже позбувся цих наслідків після в'язниці
і стверджує, що справи в нього йдуть краще.
Чи було б його життя іншим, якби не ув'язнення?
Було б у 100 разів легше.
Я не був би неодноразово засуджений,
мав би значно менше боргів.
Одним з рішень таких проблем було б
не визнавати несплату за проїзд кримінальним злочином,
відмінити § 265a Кримінального кодексу.
Цього прагнуть навіть судді і
співробітники правоохоронних органів,
таке прагнення зафіксоване і у коаліційній угоді.
Ми запитали у міністра юстиції:
коли очікувати реалізації цього рішення ?
Відповідь: «перевірка триває».
Наступного тижня королева Єлизавета II святкує
70-річний ювілей правління.
Звичайно, королева створює особливу картинку Англії
у нашому уявленні.
Букінгемський палац,
дорогий Лондон або міс Марпл -
все це на фоні ідилії пейзажів Англії.
Але є і зовсім інша Англія.
Особливо багато міст на Півночі Англії
дуже бідні і занедбані.
Це не новина.
Манчестер сумнозвісно відомий ще з 19 ст.
через поняття «Манчестерський капіталізм», який є
синонімом експлуатації і використання дитячої праці.
У 20 ст. закриття шахт у Північній Англії
принесло велику бідність.
А тепер - пандемія та Brexit
ще більше ускладнили
життя людей у цьому регіоні.
Далі - Діана Ціммерман.
Райлі вчиться життю через гру.
Раз на тиждень він приходить до
церкви в Бернлі, Північна Англія.
Що тобі тут найбільше подобається?
Їжа.
Все більше сімей у Великобританії не знають,
як їм опалювати житло чи готувати їжу.
Отець Мік вже давно відчуває
більше відповідальності за виживання парафіян,
аніж за спасіння їхніх душ.
Ми відчуваємо і бачимо справжню бідність
у таких масштабах,
які я ніколи раніше не бачив.
З нашої точки зору здається,
що традиційні світові організації
відправляють до нас все більше людей,
бо не мають ресурсів.
Десять років політики жорсткої економії
аж занадто скоротили державні пільги.
А потім були брекзит і пандемія.
Тим часом інфляція досягла 9%.
Ціни на електроенергію продовжують зростати.
Церква отця Міка роздає продукти безкоштовно.
Переважно це пожертви з багатого півдня країни.
Коли у людей немає газу,
вони не можуть нічого приготувати.
Тоді їм не потрібні й ці продуктові набори.
Опозиція і благодійні організації
місяцями б'ють на сполох,
вимагаючи екстрених виплат
для людей за межею бідності.
До них, до речі, належить
кожен п’ятий у Великобританії.
Міністр фінансів, один із найбагатших людей країни,
довго вагався.
Минулого тижня він вирішив
ввести додаткові податки
для великих нафтогазових компаній,
щоб пом'якшити найгіршу за останні 70 років кризу.
Жоден уряд не в змозі розв'язати усі проблеми,
не кажучи про складну і глобальну
проблему інфляції.
Але цей уряд ніколи не припинить
спроб допомогти людям.
Загальний пакет становить 17 мільярдів євро.
Але багато хто вважає, що навіть цього
буде недостатньо,
щоб запобігти подальшому зубожінню.
Отець Мік побоюється, що вся політична система
може втратити довіру громадян,
якщо не забезпечить більшу справедливість.
Те, що відбувається тут,
передусім на півночі Англії,
має служити моторошним попередженням
для решти Європи.
Вони повинні подивитися на Великобританію,
де відбувається застій економіки,
де багато людей помирають,
багато - бездомні,
психічно хворі і так далі,
та сприйняти це як попередження.
Лондон готується до святкування
70-ї річниці вступу королеви на трон.
Але рідко коли відмінності між багатими та бідними
в королівстві волали були такими
кричущими, як зараз.
Репортаж Діани Ціммерман
«Бідне королівство» ви зможете
подивитись у середу ввечері
і потім знайти у медіатеці.
А тепер Гайнц з новинами спорту цих вихідних.
Фінал Ліги Чемпіонів УЄФА
запам'ятався не лише спортивним тріумфом
мадридського «Реала».
Про рахунок 1:0 і події перед грою у Парижі
розповість Міхаель Кройц.
Хаос перед грою
на входах до стадіону Стад де Франс.
Вболівальники намагаються
потрапити на стадіон через паркан.
Інші незадоволені, адже навіть маючи квитки,
вони не встигають вчасно потрапити на матч.
Це просто хаос,
французи, їхня організація та УЄФА -
це просто жах.
УЄФА припускає,
що масові проблеми з входом на матч
спричинило поширення підроблених квитків.
Міністр внутрішніх справ Франції
у Twitter звинуватив
у хаосі британських вболівальників без квитків
і подякував охороні.
Вони діяли жорстко,
але, за словами англійських поліціянтів,
це не провина
вболівальників з острова.
Матч розпочався із запізненням у 36 хвилин.
Ліверпуль мав перевагу на полі,
але не зміг обіграти Куртуа,
видатного воротаря мадридців.
На відміну від Реала.
Єдиний гол матчу забив Вінісіус Жуніор.
Реал Мадрид став 14-разовим
переможцем Ліги чемпіонів.
Святковий настрій у Мадриді триває,
як і в Ліверпулі.
Александр Звєрєв пройшов у чвертьфінал
Відкритого чемпіонату Франції,
обігравши у трьох сетах іспанця Сапату Міральєса,
який почав змагання з кваліфікації.
Про Формулу 1:
Серхіо Перес виграв Гран-прі Монако.
Через дощ перегони розпочалися
на годину пізніше.
Згодом їх ще раз призупинили:
Мік Шумахер втратив контроль над болідом,
але, на щастя, не отримав травм.
У хаотичній гонці Перес фінішував першим
з невеликим відривом від Карлоса Сайнса
і чемпіона світу Макса Ферстаппена.
Кассандра Оршель з Гамбурга
несподівано стала переможницею
німецького стрибкового дербі.
Вперше за 47 років у цих змаганнях
перемогла жінка.
Вона тріумфувала на 91-му традиційному турнірі
у районі Гамбурга Кляйн Флотбек
на кобилі, на ім'я Дакара.
Вершниця, яка виступала за Польщу, та її кобила
стали єдиною з чотирьох пар,
яка не допустила жодної помилки.
Другим став Фредерік Тільман із Гревенброха.
Загарбницька війна Путіна
наблизила Україну до Європи.
І це, безперечно, взаємно:
завдяки репортажам з України
німці дізналися більше про цю країну,
її жителів, краєвиди, міста, історію.
Тоді таких білих плям не бракувало.
Це зокрема полегшило Путіну
здійснення попередніх анексій.
Здається, зараз Європа прокинулась.
Яскравим показником цього стало те,
що на Євробаченні європейська публіка
майже одноголосно проголосувала за Україну.
Переможці, гурт Kalush Orchestra, виступали сьогодні
біля Бранденбурзьких воріт
під час благодійного концерту
на підтримку України.
Репортаж Штефані Гаргош
і Лорен Мюллер з Берліну.
Біля символу свободи - Бранденбурзьких воріт
у День Києва відбувся благодійний концерт
на підтримку України.
Привіт, Європо! Привіт, світ!
Наживо з Берліну.
Українці, білоруси, німці -
тисячі людей прийшли на концерт.
Для мене це показник того,
що світ нас підтримує.
Тому що я хочу показати, що я проти війни.
Єднання Берліну та Києва сьогодні -
це дуже символічно.
Сьогодні День Києва, а ми не маємо
можливості бути вдома
тому ми прийшли сюди, щоб побути поруч
із земляками,
послухати музику та відчути український дух.
На концерті виступили 18 українських артистів.
Він наживо транслювався на українському
телебаченні та на 20 каналах в усьому світі.
У Берліні вхід був вільним.
Ми хочемо показати українську творчість
та нагадати, що в Україні, у серці Європи йде війна.
Ми також хочемо зібрати кошти на
гуманітарні та медичні потреби.
В українських лікарнях
не вистачає переносних рентгенів.
Вони сподіваються на щедрі пожертви.
На двогодинному телемарафоні були
відеопривітання артистів та політиків з усього світу
Українців привітав і голова німецького уряду.
Вітання, Києве! Вітання, Україно!
Ми на вашому боці!
Ми підтримуємо Україну, підтримуємо свободу
верховенство права
і честь наших європейських братів і сестер.
І кілька хвилин музики: Kalush Orchestra
зі своєю піснею «Стефанія»
переможці конкурсу «Євробачення».
Це дещо особливе - виступати тут, на цьому
символічному місці.
Ми сподіваємось досягти багатьох людей і
донести їм, що нам і надалі потрібна допомога.
Це їхній спосіб боротися за свою країну.
Гурт демонструє: Україна єдина і згуртована,
однак їй потрібна підтримка, також і тут, у Берліні,
коли Україна відзначає День Києва.
Війна в Україні, звісно, продовжиться
і цього тижня,
а з нею - і непередбачені проблеми,
як це завжди буває у таких війнах.
Про інші, передбачувані, події, ми, як і щонеділі,
дізнаємося в огляді тижня із Лаурою Барнік.
З вівторка пасажири зможуть три місяці
пересуватися Німеччиною з квитком за 9 євро.
Таким чином Федеральний уряд хоче
допомогти населенню впоратися з інфляцією
і популяризувати громадський транспорт.
Цю ж мету мають і знижки на паливо.
70 років тому королевою Великобританії
стала Єлизавета II.
З четверга цей ювілей буде відзначатися
впродовж чотирьох днів.
У 96 років Єлизавета II -
не лише королева, яка найдовше
править країною,
а й також найстарша у світі монархиня.
У четвер країни ООН зустрінуться у Стокгольмі
на ювілейну 50-у екологічну конференцію.
Дослідження Римського клубу в 1972 році
розпочало світову дискусію про захист клімату.
Відтоді ООН намагається
сприяти сталому розвитку
та втілювати глобальні екологічні цілі.
І прогноз погоди на початок нового тижня.
Завтра погода буде мінливою.
В Альпах і на північному сході
очікуються зливи та короткочасні грози.
У регіоні між Майном і Дунаєм буде сонячно.
Температура буде сягати від +13° до +21°.
Починаючи з вівторка щодня ставатиме
трохи тепліше.
У четвер стовпчик термометра досягне
позначок від +18° до +28°.
Переважно буде сонячно, однак подекуди
невеликі зливи та грози, здебільшого на півдні.
Це все на сьогодні.
Дивіться в ефірі шведський трилер
«Вбивство всередині літа».
О 00:30 у програмі випуск «heute Xpress».
А ми, Беттіна Шаустен і Гундула Гаузе,
чекаємо на вас завтра.
До зустрічі в ефірі!